شهراني بالكاد مره على وفاه الملكه
اليزابيث الثانيه وعلى تسلوي نجلها تشارلز
الثالث العرش حتى تعود صفحات مضطربه من
مرض الاسره الى الاضواء والسبب مسلسل
وبالتحديد الجزء الخامس من ذكراون وحتى
قبل العرض المسلسل عاصفه قويه تدور حول
ذكرى الذي يواجه تهاما بالافتراع للحياه
الملكيه خاصه فيما يتعلق بعلاقه الامير
تشارلز وقتها بزوجته الاميره ديانا وعن
ادعاءات بالتخطيط للاطاحه بالملكه
اليزابيث عن العرش
باستخدام ذكراون للترويجي لمواقف مناهضه
للملكيه نتفليكس قالت في دفاعا عن الروايه
لا يجب ان تعتبر حقيقيه وهي النسخه
المتخينه لما كان يمكن ان يحدث خلف
الابواب المغلقه للمتابعه مقطعا من هذا
الاعلان الترويجي لمسلسل ثم ننتقل الى
علاء سرحان الحديث عن الانتقاليه
ايهاب
[موسيقى]
كذب
اتسمت بحساسيه كبيره تطرق اليها مسلسل
ذكراوند وضعته في مرمى الانتقادات خاصه في
موسمه الخامس رئيسه وزراء بريطانيا الاسبق
جون نيجر شانه هجوما شديدا حول مشهد الملك
تشارلز الذي كان امير وهو يقطع عطلته مع
زوجته ديانا لاستضافه اجتماع السريه معه
عام
1991 لمناقشه الاطاحه بالملكه اليزابيث
الثانيه عن العرش مجر كتب رساله قائلا
المسلسل مؤلم للغايه لعائله لا تزال حزينه
على الشخص الذي بنيت الدراما باكملها على
حياتها ايضا يظهر المسلسل ويؤدي دوره
اثناء محاوله تجميد رئيس الوزراء الاسبق
تونير كحاليف لحمايه مستقبله وتمهيد
الطريق للزواج من كاميلا بعد فتره وجيزه
من الانتخابات العامه
1997 ردا على هذا المشهد قال المتحدث باسم
بلير هذا هو راء كامل ونتفلكس لا تحترم
ذكرى اولئك الذين لم يعودوا على قيد
الحياه اما الا ممثله جوليا دانيتش التي
ادت دوره الملكه فيكتوريا في المسلسل
فانتقدته هي الاخرى واصفه اياه بظالم
بقسوه للعائلتي الملكه